hello and welcome to see you're playing
until our tour from Finland gloat
exchange variation I definitely have to
learn something decent there for black I
keep having problems with this line and
it really shouldn't be mostly by and
playing um yeah non-standard stuff to
get more interesting positions but
mostly I get into problems yeah this is
not really threaten Alec so what to do
f6 probably how to do this open let's
put some pressure on a form
I'd like to put the bishop on c6 not
sure maybe start with this I can play
Knights you follow just for trading down
everything hmm
I wanted to go see five but it's got
nights you form
hmm yeah that's not that's not very
interesting okay let's do it anyway
he does not have to play Knights afore
you can also play rupee one and wait
wait with this move by King on da tis
not exactly well placed okay so i don't
really see the point Bishop Jake's
whoopty seven or something
maybe it's got Luke f7 now hmm I should
have thought about this for a moment no
seems you just should be five I guess
he was threatening Bishop Bishop takes
be 60 something like that was necessary
qb3 is not exactly ideal
GRC six looks interesting for up to
seven okay
a bishop is not bad on c3 I don't want
to retreat it okay wants to go on to the
7th rookie seven days we were eight
unfortunately
yeah coming on the seventh hmm maybe
both see okay i guess i have to prevent
it
look at seven was house too annoying c6
guy gasps rookie six ok cannot go back
in b7 now let's push the pawns rope d7 i
still have rookies seven i guess or this
one
and rookie six now I think should work I
just get the poor now
ok now what is this rook you too I guess
you can see seven covered prepare this
ship deform I didn't see that move
that's bad okay I have to cover it like
this and I can actually push your right
check each one
time warning check
okay what now just be 30 getting down on
time here and somewhat disconcerting hmm
not sure why I did this to be honest
check might be able to check on Jack
Teague on g7 chance to this that should
be good actually I can't remove this
either takes or give us Kim Ji Won after
which they play Bishop c5 anyway Jack I
can just about do this it's really
amazing to not win this position is a
complete disgrace again or am I quick
enough i'm actually quick enough white
resigns yeah i was said well a very
shaky conversion process yeah i think i
was very surprised that he went to be
five I thought night see for us was okay
and I thought nights you for him but
okay I can take take and here I'm
attacking this first okay so I didn't
even see that one correctly I know he
does all that
chess check check check check yeah it
didn't it wasn't probably a bad bad yeah
I can actually also take and it's a draw
yeah it was very bad very badly played
very very very badly plate here I should
just win technically without any who
should have success is very clear this
is making things already been difficult
here we trade bishops and then I go
b-two and promote yeah that's I think
controlling this year reasonably well
now after he didn't even try to get
something back this should be a fairly
easy win but I managed to screw it up
and that can't who gave two more check
check I wasn't sure bishops III is still
very clearly winning maybe Paul is just
25 months yeah bad technical player not
playing well at the moment okay thanks
for watching